ow i'm having such sharp pains right now
well on the back down here down
here
and here like i
i'm probably like at a nine on a pain
scale
let me see
oh
because i have some concern about this
pregnancy
okay because this baby i think for me
looked like a little bigger than the
other
and you know you have the support of the
cell class
is very very very short
i have an abdominal circulation put in i
have an incompetent cervix i had surgery
a few years ago it's permanent i don't
feel it and it's basically to help me
you know stay pregnant one of the
problem your baby's pushing your survey
with the legs
so the baby's basically kicking
on my surchage and the danger is that if
baby botan steps too hard he can break
my surclage and then he comes out
god forbid you say he's coming next week
is that okay
every day that bus
is better for the baby
if you delivery tomorrow you will be
like a 32 weeks
your baby will be at least four weeks at
the hopefully
but don't cry everything will be fine
with you and your baby don't worry
[Music]
four weeks
that kills me because when shy was in
the nicu it was only for like a day and
a half two days but it was just to make
sure he was okay it wasn't because he
was so early it wasn't
scary
when he
tells me about the nicu and the baby
possibly being there for four weeks if i
don't keep him in for a certain period
of time it freaks me out
what if i go sooner is it my fault
like can that be even more dangerous for
the baby
[Music]